- [Derek] Do people really
understand the scale
of the universe?
- Damn, really? That's... okay.
- This task is going to
seem ridiculously easy.
Rank these things from smallest at the top
to biggest on the bottom.
But sometimes you have to ask the question
no one would bother to
in order to figure out
what people are actually thinking.
- This is really gonna
put my astronomy skills
to the test, so.
- Moon. I don't know, moon.
- Yeah, I'd say moon
is probably the smallest.
- I'd say stars are smallest.
- But the sun is a star.
- So this is like a science quiz.
- I'll say planets are the smallest.
I'd say planet might
be the top of the line.
- Is the sun bigger than the moon?
- It depends on the planet, right?
- It does, but as a general category.
- Stars, then moons.
- And then there's stars-
- Yeah?
- Around the planet.
- The sun is a star, right?
I think.
- Yeah, it is.
- You think this one's next? I trust you.
- Dude, we're talking about a galaxy, bro.
We're talking everything.
- You're looking at the galaxy too?
(group laughs)
Okay, like, okay.
- I think it's this one and then this one.
- You're right.
- You can do it.
- Wait, no.
- Unless you believe in the
multiverse, then you know-
- I think you're taking this, like,
four-dimensional chess level.
- I think the moon would be bigger, no?
- I mean, you'd think right?
Because like it looks bigger.
- Yeah.
- Is this supposed to be like
a science lesson? (laughs)
- Like there is, there's
definitely some science to this.
- Okay.
- We are not astrology majors.
(Derek laughs)
- So what is a moon?
Like, how's a moon
different from a planet?
- It's collection of dust, maybe?
- The way that they
come about in astrology
and like the, I don't
know, like the meteors.
- Planets is like human life.
Already exists or potentially can exist.
- And a planet has its
own like, I don't know-
- Atmosphere.
- I think a planet's capable-
- Yes!
- Of having its own atmosphere
or something.
(hands slap)
- And then the atmosphere
of the moon and the planet
are completely different.
- Whether or not it
has like an atmosphere.
- I get why some people would think this,
because the Earth has an atmosphere,
while our moon has
essentially no atmosphere,
but Titan, Saturn's largest moon,
actually has a thick atmosphere,
while mercury has no
substantial atmosphere.
So if having an atmosphere
isn't what makes a planet,
then what is it?
- We don't know if the moon
has people on. It could.
- You think the moon
could have people on it?
- There could be moon
people. We never know.
- I'm thinking like orbits or something.
Something around there.
- I think natural
satellite is the term used.
So, like, you'll always have
moons around the planet.
You can't see a planet around a moon.
- How many planets do we know of?
- Uh...
- Huh. (laughs)
Mm. Mm.
(Derek laughs)
- I don't know. Well-
- Any guess?
- Let's see.
- Seven, eight?
- Seven or nine?
- Do we have 11 in our solar system?
- I think a planet has to be certain size
to be considered a planet,
'cause you look at Pluto,
they say it's not a planet
because it's too small.
- Pluto doesn't count as a planet anymore.
- Pluto's technically not a planet.
That's a dwarf planet?
- Everyone knows
the poor story of Pluto, I think.
- Because everybody loves Pluto.
(bright music)
- When Pluto was discovered in 1930,
it was hailed the ninth planet,
but it quickly became clear
that Pluto was different.
The real nail in the coffin came
(thunder cracks)
on the 5th of January, 2005,
when astronomers discovered Eris,
(gentle music)
an object in the Kuiper belt
that's around 30% more massive than Pluto.
Similar large objects had
already been discovered
and more were likely to follow.
So scientists faced a choice:
either add a whole bunch
more planets or demote Pluto.
In 2006, the decision was made,
and a new definition for
a planet was established.
- They should just, like, get over it.
- A planet anymore
- Pluto had it coming
from the beginning.
(audience applauds)
- Stay in your lane?
- Stay in your lane.
(audience applauds)
- Our moon-
- Our moon.
- Has five times the mass of Pluto.
- What?
- So just get over it.
- Is our moon a planet?
- No, it's a moon.
- [Derek] To be a planet,
an object now had to
satisfy three criteria.
First, it must orbit the sun.
Second, it must have enough self-gravity
so that it's round or almost round.
And third, it must be
gravitationally dominant
and cleared out its neighborhood.
Pluto satisfies the first two
criteria, but not the third.
So now we're back to the set
of planets without Pluto.
- Mercury, Venus, Earth, Mars, Jupiter,
Saturn, Uranus, Neptune.
Oh, it's eight.
- Nice.
(participant laughs)
And he named them all.
Bonus points.
How many planets outside the solar system?
- Oh.
- Maybe around a couple
hundred to 1,000, maybe?
- [Participant] Probably
a couple million. (laughs)
- Probably more than that.
- I mean, in terms of
the number that we know
is about 5,000 right now.
- Oh.
- That have been identified, but like,
you're right, there's many more,
but we just haven't seen
them yet, so we don't know.
So the moons are the smallest.
They go around the planets.
Planets go around the stars.
What makes a star a star?
- Kind of like a dead planet, right?
Like it's just emitting heat.
- Like little gas things.
And they explode all the time.
And we don't even see them.
But I don't know where they come from.
Can you tell me?
- If you have a bunch of
just like gas, as you say,
like hydrogen, helium, and that
all kind of clumps together,
it forms a star.
- Oh.
- And then like you say, there's
like fusion in the middle,
explosions in the middle that
are giving out light and heat
and stuff like that.
- Wow.
You just taught me something new.
I didn't even know that.
- There you go.
- Doesn't it take eight
Earths to fill the sun?
- A million Earths.
I got it wrong. Okay, I'm stupid.
- (laughs) No, no, but
like it's a lot, right?
Here's one way to put this in perspective.
In our solar system,
there are eight planets,
hundreds of moons, millions
of asteroids and more.
But in terms of mass,
all that only makes up
0.14% of the mass of our solar system.
The other 99.86% of the mass is the sun.
That is just how much bigger
and more massive the sun is.
- Moon's smallest, then planets and stars.
(students chattering faintly)
(tone beeps)
- Well, what is a galaxy?
Like, what is that?
- Uh...
- A group of planets in, I'd say,
a certain amount of proximity.
- Like the solar system.
Like the system of planets.
So like just how we have our solar system
is what makes the galaxy.
- A ton of stars, moons,
and planets in together
makes the galaxy?
- Maybe just a collection
of like solar systems?
- So how many is a
collection of solar systems?
How big is a galaxy? How many stars?
(gentle music)
- Uh...
Help.
(group laughs)
I don't know.
- Phone a friend.
- 60,000.
- Millions, I'd say, millions.
- Tens of millions of stars, perhaps?
- How many stars in a galaxy?
Roughly. Ballpark.
- Probably hundreds of millions.
- Million? Billion?
- 100 billion.
- Oh, you are way off.
- That was crazy. (laughs)
- Oh my God. (laughs)
- You said 60. 100 billion?
- 100 billion stars.
- Damn, really? That's... okay.
- Number of stars in the galaxy,
that can vary depending
on the size of the galaxy,
but like 100 billion, 200
billion, 300 billion. 50 billion,
like that's like kind
of the ballpark numbers
from the galaxy.
- Okay.
But the average is 100 billion?
- Yeah.
- That's crazy,
- Right?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- They're huge.
There's a funny question.
Are there more trees on
Earth or stars in our galaxy?
- (raspberries) Oh, actually, Mm.
I'm now thinking about like a math problem
where it's basically, you
have to find, I guess,
the whole entire surface
area that, oh, huh.
- The answer is, I'll
save you the trouble,
there are more trees on Earth
than there are stars in the
galaxy, in our Milky Way Galaxy.
- You know it figures, you know? (laughs)
- So a galaxy is a huge
collection of stars, planets, gas,
dust, dark matter, and other objects,
all bound together by gravity.
And then what is around
the Milky Way galaxy?
- More galaxies.
- There are more galaxies,
but they're kind of far away.
So what's between us and
those other galaxies?
- The...
- Uh...
- Like all types of vastness, you know?
Super novas.
- Dark matter?
- Stars? (laughs)
- You know, this is the
thing that I find nuts,
and one of the things I
wanted to see if people know,
but like the Milky Way is like one galaxy,
but it's huge.
- Right.
- It's like 100,000 light-years across.
That's pretty big.
- Mm.
- You know what I mean?
But then around us, there's nothing.
- Hmm.
- Oh wow, I didn't know that.
- Basically nothing.
- Yeah.
It's kind of like the continents, right?
That you have a continent,
but then around it,
like there's all this ocean,
and then there's like more galaxies,
and then there's nothing,
and then more galaxies,
nothing more galaxies, nothing.
But this animation is not to scale.
Really, it should look more like this.
The distances between
galaxies are enormous,
typically millions of light-years.
If you zoom out further,
you find that galaxies
are grouped together in clusters,
and those clusters make up
even larger superclusters,
all separated by enormous voids.
And you know how many galaxies
there are in the universe?
- I'll take a guess and
say like 20-something.
- How many galaxies in the universe?
- (beep) If I know. (laughs)
- 12? I don't know.
Is it? Is that like close?
- It's more, much more.
- 20?
Oh, much more.
- I'm gonna say 100.
- More than hundreds.
- Thousands?
- More than thousands.
- (laughs) Oh my gosh.
- 10,000.
(participants laughs)
- 10,000?
- 10,000.
- That's small.
- I mean 10,000 galaxies,
but each galaxy's got 100 billion stars.
- 16,482.
- Hundreds of thousands?
Millions? Billions?
- 1 billion?
- Or, is that too small?
- 1 billion galaxies, each
one with 100 billion stars?
- I'll say 10 billion that we know of.
- What are you gonna say?
- The answer is...
- How many galaxies in the universe?
About?
Oh jeez. (laughs)
(wind rustling)
100 billion.
- What, really?
- About 100 billion galaxies.
- Holy. Seriously?
- Yeah.
About 100 billion.
- Dang, weird.
- Oh man.
(participants laugh)
- It's huge.
100 billion are observable.
- And these are just galaxies?
- These are galaxies.
Each galaxy then has
about 100 billion stars.
- Okay.
- Right?
That's mind blowing a little bit.
- Yeah.
- This is what I'm saying.
I feel like most people don't know
the scale of the universe,
and that's what I'm
out here to talk about.
- Mm-hmm.
- That's why I wanted to be,
like, it's so much bigger
than almost anyone thinks.
- Right.
- In fact, there could be even more,
because 100 billion galaxies
is a conservative estimate.
Some believe there are
up to 2 trillion galaxies
in the observable universe.
So it's huge, and between
all these galaxies,
nothing.
- Just nothing.
- What a wacky universe, right?
- [Participant] Yeah.
- And around each star,
there might be, on
average, about six planets.
- Wow.
- So you can think
about 100 billion times 100
billion times six, roughly,
and that's conservative.
- Okay.
- Kind of like number of
planets may be in the universe.
- Mm-hmm.
- So it's insanely huge.
- Yes. That sounds...
That is actually, wow.
- I feel like it makes me less stressed,
because it's just a
blip in the system, man.
Nothing's ever that deep.
(gentle music)
- Whoa. (laughs)
- So the universe
is insanely huge.
- And we're incredibly small.
I got you.
(Derek laughs)
- How does that make you feel?
- Very small.
- To think about the size of it.
- I don't know.
It doesn't make you feel that small.
- Nope?
- Because there's not-
- You still feel pretty big?
(participant laughs)
- I don't feel big,
but you know, I still feel like
this Earth in particular
has a pretty decent amount
of significant whatever,
you know, significance.
- This is a special place, for sure.
- Yeah.
On the 14th of February, 1990,
the Voyager 1 spacecraft was
about 6 billion kilometers
from the sun when it took this picture.
All you see are a few rays
of light and a little dot.
Carl Sagan described this picture best.
(gentle music)
"Look again at that dot.
That's here, that's home, that's us.
On it, everyone you
love, everyone you know.
Everyone you ever heard of,
every human being who ever
was lived out their lives,
every hero and coward,
every creator and
destroyer of civilization,
every young couple in love,
every mother and father,
inventor and explorer,
every superstar, every supreme leader,
every saint and sinner
in the history of our species lived there,
on a mote of dust suspended in a sunbeam."
The earth is a very small
stage in a vast cosmic arena.
To me, it underscores our responsibility
to deal more kindly with one another,
and to preserve and
cherish the pale blue dot,
the only home we've ever known.
- I'm glad you taught me something today.
I appreciate it. I like learning.
- That's awesome.
Well, thank you for
being open to learning,
'cause that's so important.
- The thing that people are worried about
is making mistakes, but you can't learn
without making mistakes a lot of times.
(bright music)
- So many people don't know the basics
about the universe we live
in, but it can even be hard
to understand the world we live in,
and this has a lot to do
with our media ecosystem,
which often prioritizes
speed over accuracy
and sensationalism over facts,
the problem that's so big
in science communication,
I made a whole video about it.
But Ground News, the
sponsor of this video,
changes the game by giving you the tools
to consume news in a more
nuanced and transparent way.
It was founded by a former NASA engineer,
and it gathers articles from
around the world in one spot.
So Ground News shows how different outlets
cover the same story and gives you context
about the source of the information.
Take a look at this study on
America's trust in science.
I can see that more than 10
articles were published on it,
and if I scroll down, I can
read them all in one place.
Next to each headline,
there are tags showing me
who owns the outlet, how
reliable their reporting is,
and if they have a political bias.
What's interesting is that some headlines
just mention a decline in trust,
some link it to COVID, and
others focus on the trend
being worse in minorities.
Ground News also gives a
bias distribution chart,
showing me that this
story is mostly covered
by center-leaning sources
with little coverage from the
left and none from the right,
so for readers living in a
right-leaning media bubble,
this would be a blind spot.
Ground News actually
sorts stories like this
into a separate feed so
you can see what topics
both sides of the political
spectrum tend to focus on
and make sure you are
getting the full picture.
Go to ground.news/veritasium
to check it out,
or click the link in the description.
And if you sign up using our link,
you'll get 30% off their
unlimited access plan.
A subscription helps support Ground News
to make the media
landscape more transparent.
So I would like to thank Ground News
for sponsoring this video,
and I'd like to thank you for watching.